and you can expect to see more cones and
lane closures on i-15 near the strip in
just a couple of hours crews will be
starting a project that will upgrade the
i-15 tropicana interchange we're giving
you dinner options too
give governor systec and transportation
secretary pete butterjudge launching the
project at allegiant stadium today joe
moeller shows us how this could impact
your commute
with the legion stadium now open and
bringing traffic to the area ndot says
it is time to replace the 60 year old
i-15 tropicana interchange this project
will cost millions of dollars and takes
several years to complete slot machines
they're parts inner workings things like
that we sell rachel mcdermott works at
gaming and entertainment touch
technology traffic traffic traffic it's
bumper to bumper being blocks away from
allegiant she is used to the traffic
headaches it's a struggle getting out on
the weekends i think it's a really good
idea tuesday governor steve syslock
joined transportation secretary pete
butterjudge to officially launch the
i-15 tropicana interchange project this
is going to make transportation better
safer and more convenient the project
includes an expansion of tropicana a new
bridge over the freeway a new flyover
exit from the 15 to eastbound tropicana
and a new alignment for dean martin for
traffic to flow smoothly under tropicana
crews begin work tuesday night and will
go through 2024. here we are in a place
that is experiencing such extraordinary
growth in jobs in population in economic
activity which brings a lot of
challenges to support that growth with
adequate infrastructure to keep it going
because of the project 305 million
dollars 50 million of that coming from a
department of transportation grant about
4 600 jobs will be connected to the
project as well i think i would be
willing to deal with a little bit of a
headache mcdermott knows this means more
traffic cones and lane closures are
coming but worth it i think it's going
to really help alleviate traffic i think
that after events it will definitely
make people getting home a lot easier a
lot safer too so how much of a traffic
problem will this cause on the roads a
representative from ndot says the major
closures that will impact traffic won't
be taking place until early 2023 and
that includes some short temporary
closures of the 15th reporting near the
strip joe muller live local now